what the world has been waiting to see
eg broke this news just a few months ago
that Janet Jackson is pregnant now only
we can show you for the first time miss
Jackson blossoming at fifty
there's the mom-to-be smile on her face
braided hair held back by a bandana
Janet looks comfortable wearing a scarf
a loose-fitting black top baggy pants
and sneakers putting an end to rumors
that she's hired a surrogate Janet made
the very rare public appearance going
shopping in London at 4:45 p.m.
Janet her bodyguard and entourage of
three others arrived to the high-end
boutique back in action which sells some
baby products but mostly things to
relieve back pain last week Janet's
sister latoya confirmed the 50 year old
has been told by doctors to reduce her
activity how's Janet she's doing case
she doing good and how how's the
pregnancy is it going to go she's
resting on bed rest and she's doing
fabulous are you ready to meet your new
little niece or nephew years before
Janet spent 45 minutes inside and left
with just this small white bag what's
interesting though is the place actually
offers a float Center to pregnant women
while some get massages here another
option is being encased in this orange
pod filled with warm water the process
is believed to relieve stress and strain
on the mother's body my husband and I
are planning our family I have to rest
up doctor's orders
Janet's husband is of course 41 year old
billionaire businessman with saumya mana
and a source today gave us this pregnant
at 50 update Janet is due around early
November and it doesn't look like she's
having twins I am so excited for Janet
you know this year is the 30th
anniversary of her groundbreaking
control album and she's definitely
taking control of her life
you